WAS ACCURATE.
BEN SMITH IS THE EDITOR AND
CHIEF OF BUZZ FEED NEWS.
HE WAS GAME ENOUGH TO JOIN US.
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO JOIN US.
NOT HIS FIRST TIME ON THE SHOW.
I AM THANKFUL YOU CAME.
FIRST THE DOSSIER.
THIS IS A SINCERE QUESTION.
YOU PUBLISH THE DOSSIER AND WE
DEBATED WHETHER THAT WAS A WISE
MOVE BUT YOU DID.
WE LEARNED IN THE TESTIMONY THAT
COHEN DID NOT GO TO PRAGUE.
WE ONLY BELIEVED HE WENT TO
PRAGUE BECAUSE YOU RAN THE
STORY.
YOU NEVER RAN A FOLLOW-UP STORY
INFORMING YOUR READERS OF THAT.
WHY?
>> THAT'S TOTALLY FALSE.
IN WEEKS OF PUBLISHING THE
DOSSIER, WE WERE REACHING OUT TO
COHEN AND WE PHOTOGRAPHED THE
INSIDE OF HIS PASSPORT.
WE PUBLISHED HIS DENIAL THAT HE
WENT TO PRACTICING.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
I JUST READ THAT STORY 20
MINUTES AGO.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Tucker: I JUST READ THE STORY
YOU PUBLISHED.
IT DID NOT SAY BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T HAVE EVIDENCE THAT HE
DIDN'T GO TO PRACTICING.
-- PRAGUE.
LAST WEEK WE HAD HIM UNDER OATH
SAYING HE DIDN'T GO TO PRAGUE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE HEADLINES OUT
OF THE HEARING.
YET YOU IGNORED IT.
SINCE YOU PUBLISHED THE DOSSIER
DON'T YOU HAVE THE OBLIGATION TO
TIE THE BOW AND TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE END?
>> WE COVERED THE HELL OUT OF
THAT.
>> Tucker: IF I READ A STORY --
>> I AM SURPRISED YOU THINK THAT
COHEN'S LATEST STATEMENT MAKES
IT MORE OF A FACT.
IT WAS NOT A NEW DEVELOPMENT.
>> Tucker: WE GET TO ASK MICHAEL
COHEN IN PUBLIC.
HE HAS EVER REASON TO TELL US IF
YES, HE WENT TO PRAGUE AND
EVERYTHING YOU THINK ABOUT TRUMP
IS TRUE.
HE HATES TRUMP.
NOW HE CAN TELL US THE TRUTH.
HE TELLS US THE OPPOSITE, NO HOO
DID NOT GO.
THE DOSSIER CLAIMED -- CARTER
PAGE'S LIFE WAS DESTROYED --
THAT HE RECEIVED 11 BILLION
DOLLARS FROM A RUSSIAN ENERGY
COMPANY IN A DEAL.
HE DIDN'T.
I DON'T THINK BUZZ FEED EVER
TOLD US THAT.
WHY NOT?
>> WE PUBLISHED THE DOSSIER AT
THE TIME NOT BECAUSE WE HAD BEEN
ABLE TO STAND UP OR KNOCK DOWN
EVERY ALLEGATION.
WE SAID UNVERIFIED DOCUMENT AND
IT'S IMPORTANT PUBLIC DOCUMENT
AT THE HEART OF AN FEB.
INVESTIGATION.
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT THIS LAST
TIME I GOT THE IMPRESSION YOU
AGREED WITH THAT.
NUNES SAID THERE WAS A SECRET
DOCUMENT.
IT MAKES MY CASE BUT YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO SEE IT.
YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
ARGUMENTS YOU MADE ABOUT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND THE
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER SIDE SAYING
THIS DOCUMENT WILL SCALD YOUR
EYES OUT IF YOU LOOK AT IT.
>> Tucker: I GET IT.
I SAID IT AT THE TIME, I THINK
THAT'S NOT A CRAZY ARGUMENT TO
MAKE.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: IN FAVOR OF OPENNESS.
YOU ARE A JOURNALIST AND NOT
SIMPLY A GUY WHO RUNS A
PLATFORM.
YOU ARE NOT RUNNING GOOGLE.
YOU ARE RUNNING A NEWS SITE.
YOU INJECT THESE CLAIMS AND
DON'T FOLLOW-UP.
IF I RUN A PIECE BY YOUR
NEIGHBOR SAYING BEN SHOT
SOMEBODY, DON'T I HAVE AN
OBLIGATION WHEN YOU GET
ACQUITTED TO COVER THAT STORY.
WHY DOESN'T YOU?
>> SOME OF THEM ARE VERY, VERY
HARD TO CONFIRM OR KNOCK DOWN.
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND HIS AIDE.
COHEN WAS STRAIGHTFORWARD.
>> Tucker: AND CARTER PAGE'S
LIFE WAS DESTROYED.
HE CAN'T GET A JOB.
CONSIDERED A RUSSIAN SPY AND
NEVER BEEN CHARGED WITH
ANYTHING.
YOUR DOSSIER ADDED TO THE
PERSPENSION  -- PERCEPTION HE IS
NOT A LOYAL PERSON.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE TRUMP TOWER
IN MOSCOW AND THIS GUY LIVES
WITH THIS CLAIM AGAINST HIS NAME
AND YOU HAVE NOT CORRECTED IT.
>> WE REPORTED ON CARTER PAGE
AND HIS CONTACT WITH RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE BACK IN THE DAY AND
WE TALKED TO HIM.
HE WAS AT MY OFFICE SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO AT A RECEPTION.
I DON'T KNOW HOW CARTER PAGE
FEELS, BUT WE HAVE CARRIED HIS
SIDE OF THIS.
YOU DISMISSED SOMETHING BEFORE.
A LOT OF IT IS THE COLLUSION
STORY AND THE WILD ALLEGATIONS
OF COLLUSION.
THE TOWER STORY THAT MICHAEL
COHEN IS GOING TO JAIL ABOUT
LYING, THE STORY YOU FEEL
COHEN -- AND YOU I DISAGREE ON
WHAT COHEN SAID.
IT'S NOT A COLLUSION STORY.
IT'S A REAL ESTATE STORY.
>> Tucker: I AM AWARE OF THAT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> YOU SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT CATS.
>> Tucker: I CLAIM I MADE IN THE
OPEN.
HERE YOU HAVE COHEN AND THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION BOTH
DEBUNKING THE SO-CALLED
BOMBSHELL YOU RAN IN JANUARY.
YOU ARE REFUSING TO ADMIT IT'S
BEEN BEDUNKED.
I PAID TWO PIECES OF TAPE OF
MICHAEL COHEN SAYING IT'S NOT
TRUE AND YOU SAID IT'S STILL
TRUE ON WHAT COUNT?
>> MICHAEL COHEN WAS SAYING IN
HIS WAY HE WAS TELLING ME TO
LIE.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS DISPUTE
THAT COHEN CLAIMS, YOU COULD SAY
HE WAS LYING, HE CLAIMS TRUMP
WAS TELLING HIM TO LIE.
WHEN THIS FIRST WENT OUT YOU
CALLED IT A HOAX.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT WHAT YOUR
PIECE SAID.
HE TOLD HIM TO.
>> COHEN DESCRIBED IN MEETINGS.
COHEN DESCRIBED PERSONAL MEETING
WITH JAY SEKULOW AND TRUMP.
EVERYONE IS CHASING FOR MORE
DETAILS.
IT'S HARD TO ARGUE WITHOUT A
TRANSCRIPT OF THE MEETING.
TRUMP SAID NO RUSSIA, NO DEAL.
THAT'S PERSONAL.
TALKING ABOUT THE TESTIMONY.
IS IT THAT EXPLICIT?
THAT'S A REASONABLE ARGUMENT.
SAYING THE WHOLE STORY IS ABOUT
A HOAX.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
LOOK, I WANT TO SAY ONCE AGAIN,
I RESPECT YOU COMING ON TO
DEFEND YOUR REPORTING.
MOST PEOPLE WON'T AND YOU WILL.
I THINK YOU DESERVE A LOT OF
CREDIT.
BUT IT'S THE DETAILS THAT MATTER
IN LIFE AS IN NEWS STORIES.
YOUR STORY SAID, HE EXPLICITLY
TOLD COHEN TO LIE.
COHEN WAS ASKED TWICE BY TWO
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
IF THAT WAS TRUE AND SAID IT WAS
UNTRUE.
WHY NOT SAY PARTS OF OUR STORY
WERE RIGHT BUT WE WENT TOO FAR
AND MADE A CLAIM WE CAN'T BACK
UP?
THE SUBJECT OF THE ALLEGATION
DENIES AND WE ADMIT IT?
>> I THINK AS JASON SAID THAT
THE BAR SEEMS TO BE DID HE SAY,
MICHAEL, I NOW INSTRUCT YOU TO
LIE.
ANYTHING SHORT OF THAT?
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHAT YOUR
PIECE SAYS.
>> IN THE CONTEXT OF HIS SYSTEM,
NO RUSSIA, NO DEAL.
DETAILS OF THAT EXCHANGE MATTER
A LOT.
WHERE AND HOW HE SAID THAT.
IT MATTERS A LOT.
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER TRUMP IS
DIRECTING AND ORDERING PEOPLE
AND HOW HE IS TALKING ABOUT IT
IS SOMETHING EVERYBODY IS
WRESTLING WITH IT.
YOU SAW THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORT THAT HE ORDERED KELLY TO
DO SOMETHING BUT DIDN'T THE
EXACT WORDS.
MICHAEL COHEN WORKED FOR HIM A
LONG TIME.
IT'S NOT CRAZY THAT HE SHOULD BE